we started that preparation
of course we have already had conversations with people
who are potentially candidates
those walking people can also register
a number of people have that today
also done again
do you have a way of saying
I make sure it doesn't get out of hand
because everyone knows
of course the dangers of new parties
how that can go wrong well
what are your methods of doing that then
we will check that out
we will first see how big that group is
so we have a decent amount of people
that helps me
to put together a team
and then we look at how to submit an electoral list
how long it is
but also where,
for example
that is a possibility
but you ask that here
on the second day that the party exists
so yes i know that
you will see that before October 9
an option to say
I only do it in certain districts and others don't
it's not the preferred option
I can assure you that
you come with a prime minister is candidate
have you ever asked this question to a party
which has not been established for two days
well I think it's a normal question anyway
if you are going to participate in the elections
then you want to know
you are a well-known room than you think
that it is not there yet
but are you going to come up with a prime ministerial candidate
we will do that in the coming months
all see for November 22